I'm just in the future of machine
learning we have a diverse West Coast
panel from Seattle to San Diego the way
fabric structure this is each panelist
has been charged to and here we have one
more to join us to to tell us what they
think are one or two important
computational challenges for with
machine learning in mind and what the
future might be and they've been given a
cap of five minutes so the plan is to
let them go through those if you have a
pressing question that must be asked
immediately please do but otherwise
we'll open it up for questions after the
finish and then completely random order
I will ask you have to kicked off okay
you are frying from San Diego who's a
you know pioneer for machine learning
clay and zero for me so um yeah so I
think that you can think about various
things that are important for machine
learning but I think that what emerges
for me
years is that communication is this as
important when we basically think about
distributed algorithm which we are now
over thinking about because because
that's the only way to work within very
large data sets question is how much can
we what is the least amount that we can
communicate and still achieve our task
general we think about communication is
something that happens in the background
is a pretty matter but if you think
about the barrier model that is the
current most used model in which the
workers work in parallel and then report
that to be the master their
communication scales with the number of
of workers and so if you start to have
too many workers the time to communicate
dominates the time and I know it from
experience because I've been running
various tests on my spark cluster and it
seems like no matter what I do the
average load on the CPUs is around 5% so
so something else is blocking it and
seems like it's the
moving right marine plasm from the mr.
washington optimization expert on
mobility hi so yeah so my background is
actually in optimization before that was
also more electrical engineering so
signal passing and control so I'm newer
to machine learning I've learned a lot
of machine learning by participating in
this sequence of workshops and the
program here at silence so one thing I
wanted to mention that I have seen in
concept came up is from the point of
view of optimization is that we
understand convex optimization problems
very well but a lot of problems that
arise in machine learning are not convex
so people nowadays are talking a lot
about non convex optimization but the
problem is saying something is non
convex is not saying anything about it
so we need to start to actually
formalize a set of assumptions of how
you're going to go away from convexity
there's a lot of recent work in this
area but there is still a lot that is
open some of the recent work have been
on very specific problem structures and
cases where then you can say a lot under
strict assumptions for example you can
even say that the global optimum of an
optimization problem can be reached by a
simple algorithm and this you can reach
the global and so there's no question
from a certain type of starting point
for example that you can generate for
that type of problem but the restrict
the setting in which this works is very
restricted for example the dictionary
learning models or things like that what
about more general problems that don't
have all those assumptions there you
might have problems in which you have
many local minima but you want to have a
way of saying what is a good solution
for my problem is a local minimum good
is a particular type of local minimum
good so these are questions that are
still open so for example from machine
learning perspective you may not want
the global minimum if the global minimum
is a very deep and narrow type of
minimum maybe you are more interested in
flatter broader types of local minima so
characterizing what
what is it that we want from the
solution which also relates to what you
do with your model after was a
generalization for example that's
another another issue and from a
computational point of view two big
issues and non convex optimization or
the fact that setting the step size in
an iterative algorithm is not obvious
anymore as as opposed to convex
optimization and secondly that stopping
criteria is not it's not obvious you
don't know exactly when to stop so so
the question then boils down to what
kind of soft classes of non convex
optimization problems can be studied for
which we can say something systematic
about about these questions so and I can
discuss it more if there's interest in
specific wrapping around we have the big
cup from Burpee um this must be a high
point of his career as the director of
assignment since - since I don't work in
machine learning I won't say anything
very deep but I would like to share a
few impressions impressions if you will
an outsider to the area so the usual
model of supervised learning is very
very general and simple it's the problem
of inferring the function from values of
a set of sample points to give the setup
and generate in incomplete form you have
to press specified training data
is represented the learning algorithm
being used the space of possible
hypotheses for the function and possibly
including a map the unloading
distribution of those possibilities and
also often an action based on the
function values which may bring the
learning algorithm into propinquity to
cyber-physical system Sara we've seen
recently that deep learning seems to
have the size of advantages over more
rule-based methods such as regression or
support thinking machines of busy
networks
they've been successes in recognizing
objects faces spoken words translating
from one language to another
self-driving cars etc but I see a number
of issues of concern with respect to the
use of deep learning first of all very
large training sets are needed secondly
it's not clear that there's a
well-defined function being sought being
inferred because the different experts
may differ on the classification of the
inputs to the training set so
is a kind of issue of gathering data
from many sources that may some extend
conflict there's the issue already
raised that the problem of choosing the
most probable function in a is a convex
optimization problem with all the
difficulties associated but another
issue is the issue of comprehensibility
if you get a very deep net with a huge
number of neurons at 150 layers or more
and it succeeds in the classification
process but what have you learned what
are the what are the fundamental
features how can you get your mind
around what the door will repeat that
was doing and if you really can't
compactly specify the performance of the
deep net you're susceptible to
adversarial attacks where an algorithm
might be able to construct examples
is this faulty gives the wrong result
issues of safety if you don't have the
specification of what the net is doing
how can you guarantee that it won't go
wild and mess up your nuclear reactor
robot that that's being controlled by
the decision so there's the issue of
safety and there's also the issue of
rigidity that unlike human learning
where you learn concepts over time in a
variety of environments with more and
more examples eventually making you more
and more expert here the format is sort
of frozen you have a function with a
given domain and given rain a given
seventies and so forth so we've got a
static model in which there isn't one of
autonomy or plasticity so the model
certainly doesn't correspond to the way
that the humans or biological systems
learn and I'll just conclude by
mentioning that there's a an interesting
call for proposals from DARPA in which
they ask for the development of
next-generation machine learning
technologies that can learn from new
situations and apply that learning to
become better and more reliable while
remaining constrained with set limits so
this is learning on the fly rather than
learning from a fixed training set and I
think
the applications in the future will
require that flexibility and
adaptability
[Applause]
next we have marina Milan who might not
have prepared enough for this but misty
has color slides
statistician and data scientist from
Washington so I'm excited about that I
will talk less if I have slides what
makes me thinking more everything is
that additional challenges in machine
learning at least it always come with
statistical charts as well and to give
just a few examples if the data is so
big and divided on so many computers can
we really believe it come from the same
distribution or that it is identically
distributed or that we have removed from
it all the defendants collected okay so
so I will not belabor this point I want
to also stress that this is not always a
curse it's also also a blessing because
there is accumulating evidence from
various parts of the of machine learning
that sometimes easy data helps with
implies easy computation and the other
way around and when I say easy data it
means that the data somehow fits the
task we have in mind for it so one
example is in classification when the
classes are separated it is known that
the low there exists no noise conditions
which allow one to both learn fast and
to learn from few examples and more
generally when the data fits the task
one can prove that the learning rates
are faster
and this has been approved also in other
in supervised learning tasks now of
course it doesn't seem to be a time to
think of easy data when we can learn on
hard data as well so the second point I
want to make is that there are two ways
of learning or two objective of learning
one is prediction and in which I include
prediction on what's the next action so
learning to act and explanation and the
difference between prediction and
explanation is that in explanation in
prediction any model that does well is a
satisfactory where is an explanation we
want somehow that the description of the
data be unique or that they have very
few descriptions of the data that are
comparing otherwise we can't call it an
explanation what I see today is that
prediction is insert from certain points
of view soft but explanation is not like
the problem of explanation is much
further behind and I see this as a big
challenge both in terms of statistics as
from the point of view of computation
like they cannot go separately a related
question that you may ask is do I need
explanation why if you can just predict
why do we actually need to do any
efforts to explain what we are seeing
and I argue that there are some reasons
to do that ask me later and finally I
think a big challenge again both runs
the statistics and the computation point
of view is validation validating the
models that we have learned and thank
you so I made this slide and this is the
purpose of the talk to see how and this
is very approximate least correct or add
to it if you like
where does the where is machine learning
most successful most pervasive and what
it's not and it looks like on the left
at least in my opinion machine learning
is actually in the driver's seat whereas
on this side it's not so much so so
what's the difference between these two
on the Left I don't know if you see the
right it's easy to validate the results
we can tell when a speech recognizers
works well fairly easy of course we have
a test set but in the ultimate reality
test it's easy to tell whether the we
are doing a good job on on the left side
and hand side but not so much on the
right hand side in physics it can take
decades to validate the hypothesis and
from the point of view of what's
happening on the right hand side machine
learning is really not so useful machine
learning can generate hypotheses very
fast but when it's expensive to get
labeled data because you need to have a
trained expert to give you it just one
label data point then machine learning
is not doing such such a good job and we
need to think of how to actually both
generate hypotheses and validate
hypotheses so do the human job do the
human job of testing scientific
hypothesis investing explanations and I
think of this as a computational
challenge because of this in the large
size of the data it is hard to apply the
statistical methods that we have for
smaller for smaller models in a second
aspect of the validation is that when we
have a large trained model and this was
being brought up most recently by by
dick just before me it is important also
validate the results and we have to be
more creative again we can't expect
classical model selection or model
validation to work but we have to be
able to actually come computationally
find methods that at least locally can
tell us whether a data point or the next
prediction is trustworthy or not and
this this is all physics
I think we have like charter working to
let a few movements of the machinery
that see we thinks this coming yeah so I
resonate with a lot of the issues were
talked about already I don't think it's
so much a computational sure that I
guess the framing was what's you know
where the computation was intended so
I'd actually disagree that doing about
the convexity story
I think these deep neural nets are not
hard optimize you can see it at a zero
air with no trouble I think if you have
a wide enough one there's lots of paths
and I think there's even some kind of
folk wisdom that there's a paper I think
that from every point there's actually a
downhill path to the global one so I
don't think it's actually that that's
there are a lot of problems there but I
don't think it's necessarily it I still
think it's all statistical and I think
resonate too low a lot marina said you
know we've borrowed the mathematics of
statistics a lot heard about covering
numbers and so and so forth and risks
and so on but we still don't think like
statisticians so we don't think about
the data gathered a is probably not
likely to be much like the day to get
tomorrow there's lots of changes all
Tobias's how was it sampled probably it
was not sampled probably it's not a
random sample he'll take that into
account you're gonna make the wrong
decisions and wrong inferences and
you'll curse you if you value you'll
find that out but I think it's too late
and so you know we've been developing
machine learning in systems like search
and vision and speech where if you make
an error it's just a little bit of a
pain so I'm gets a loud noise but for
deploying them and in finance in
medicine and transportations also forth
errors are gonna be deaths and arrows
going to be chaos
so we don't have we're not ready for
that world where we really have real
confidence intervals on our outputs we
have these black boxes that give out an
answer right and no one is hardly anyone
is talking enough about well are you
sure about that how sure are you so if
you're going to go into the doctor's
office in the future the doctor will
take your genome in addition to all your
vital signs and all that and they'll put
it to a big system you know that used
machine learning it'll have done all the
data from all the other people and maybe
people like you hopefully not just
random people and all the results of all
the and it'll come out and say doctor
look at and say ie well you know the
neural net output a number which was
0.62 and any number of point six you
have to have a liver operation all right
what are you gonna say well you just
like a current CEO says I'm not gonna
try it you know tell me there's you know
who how that number rise and what are
the confidence intervals if you said
well confidence interval is huge I'm
gonna say well can I get more data oh
yeah you gotta get some more data and so
on so this is to me the issue it's it's
building systems that are able to
respect those kind of uncertainties
making decisions so you know you've make
a decision that in this image there's a
cat and you make a decision in the next
image here's a cat it's on you you do
that for days on end well your error
rate is now uncontrolled for each
decision maybe you have a calibration
you know the jury is something but what
about an ensemble of decisions and what
about when the decisions are all related
which is the real life most decisions
are related raceways well we're not
talking about that so anyway statistical
people talk about a lot and I keep my
role and machine learnings keep people
away from the idea this is just
computation
this is inference folks in
decision-making and so you got to think
like that you got to think about my data
set actually came from something out
there how did it arise what am I trying
to say about things out there in the
world and others I'll just borrow the
techniques in the math and the theorems
and all this
this is what let's think about the whole
style of of inference also we talk about
control we're all kind of starting to
get more now towards active things and
control it all that well control as soon
as you know causes right because if I
just have a bunch of variables to wiggle
and I have some desired outcome and I
wiggle that and it doesn't cause that in
any way they're just correlated well I
can wiggle it all day long and it's not
going to is going to happen if you'll
assume you already know the vector of
you know control signals and you wiggle
it you see what reinforcements are you
at the end well in real life you don't
know you're a public policy plan or a
city planner you don't know what
variables to change should I put a stop
sign there or whatever and so you've got
a reason from your day to do causal
influence again it's their little field
over that machine only we pay far too
little attention to that because if you
do control you got to know the causes
all right and then if you do control you
better worry about all the stability
issues all the unmodeled dynamics that
you're possibly exciting by putting your
control in there because stability in
systems that are time critical and our
death critical is going to cause chaos
right so I just think we're way
unprepared for this and I also think
maybe our last point is the critical a
critical issue we have to face in this
community is how to talk about our work
without all the hype and how to take on
projects that are like alphago that's
sure to create a storm of publicity and
then a storm of discussion about future
robots taking over and a storm of talk
about how intelligent everything is when
we know it's not which is nonsense and
and just a storm of things that have
nothing with the real problems is that
we're about ready to build a big systems
that go out and get deployed and are
going to cause lots and lots of problems
so let's take on problems that aren't
alphago let's take on real problems that
have to do with water and health and
climate and stuff like that that aren't
going to go into the new york times but
are rather going to make a real impact
on real lives and make our world a
better place and not go for this we're
the glorious new wave of you know it's
exciting computer scientists who were
three superhumans so I think we're
somehow it's got we've got taken over by
by that spirit if it's got to be this
you know super grandiose thing and I
just I don't recognize it this is not
full audio it's a fallacy we just go one
by one of us questions sorry no it's
open I have a question that um so when I
when I uh so I was the moderator for the
last panel and I got criticized
afterwards for not asking the following
question and it's been come up a lot so
I think it's good to ask the question is
what role maybe even especially in the
short term should theory have in this
kind of current empirical wave machine
learning my talk yesterday was exactly
that's how I started the talk and I'm
trying to reassure all the young people
in the room that actually most of the
cool problems now our theory ones so the
ones that he was a little communication
for example that's those are theory
problems whether you start to have a
synchrony distributed and communication
issues all the classical guarantees for
matrix completion or regression are out
the window you know so those are all you
know wonderful important theory
questions and all the things about how
do you get confidence intervals and
scale and how do you do things in a
temporal way those are theory issues if
you just do it you know I write
something down I tried on a test set
that's not for the next generation of
people who want to see they want to see
that you formal structure of the problem
and you pieced it apart and build
systems based so you really think that
all this empirical wave that the next
generation of young scientists or young
people like ourselves are going to come
along and say oh great they succeeded
that free Genosha at making a robot work
it's all done machine learning was
solved let's go on to other things know
I don't find your answer fully
satisfying it because it feels like
there is just feels like there is kind
of a empirical wave seems did not really
be paying attention theory and really
considering and you know the artist
content running SGD for everything and
they are you content just increasing the
size in that they are content me you
know just kind of adding hand aids when
those huge numbers of training labels
right there not good tenant they don't
have lots of labels right they don't do
it I would say that that a lot of the
hype that is currently generated is
because a lot of it is driven by a
company like Google and these companies
are basically treating it as as a
playground it's not it is not what they
sell you know like what they really
depend on they they are not using neural
network but ok so they will very
something here and very something there
I think that a lot of it has to do just
with the expectation so one of the one
of the acronyms that I really like the
least is AI education intelligence
because we have no idea what is
intelligence and therefore artificial
intelligence you know it's not I like a
slightly different term but that is much
less exciting I a which is intelligence
amplification which is real term and I
haven't invented it and it's basically
the idea that we use computers to
enhance our ability to do a lot of the
Drudge work for us but at the end it's
our decision right so the problem with
that term is that it's hard to excite
young people about it that's the really
the problem with it but I think that
it's still a very valid term and then
when you look at it from that angle you
know work like how do you estimate the
mean and variance when you have a large
fraction of outliers that's important so
I think I think a lot of the of the of
the kind of overhyped excitement is
because now everything is AI
now everybody is using AI maybe even
people are not really changing what they
did but now they call it AI just a small
thing to add at least from an
optimization point of view what Siri can
do is to for example help us understand
and justify some heuristics that are
used in practice and seem to work very
well and then when we understand them
for example why is it that they work
what is it about this class of problems
that seems to make them much better than
what worst case theory says then we can
improve these heuristics and we can
apply them more robustly so there is a
lot of room quickly I want to add just
one short thing that before we wanted to
understand various other data sources
and that was the job of machine learning
now we have also neural networks as
additional data sources and the job of
theories to understand this new process
that we have created just as we used to
understand the others I agree all it's
been said with all it's been said and I
would just add that when you start
dealing with safety critical
applications controlling robots health
systems at driving a car and so forth
you better have firm theoretical
guarantees of the performance to
understand that your system is not going
to go wild
what if asked if you feel it it is also
you need from theory to come up with new
definitions and somehow before we try to
do theorems in but on the issues that
you will mention whether maybe we don't
have that I wanted like now what kind of
questions we should ask they don't suite
up on foot even the sensory yeah briefly
uh yeah I think that's actually at least
again in optimization that's definitely
the case that they need to formulate the
questions better
so what property of optimization problem
that is not complex seems to be making
it easy and also when we say we want to
find a solution what are we talking
about what kind of solutions of interest
COBOL minimum a local minimum a kind of
local minimum do you want to
differentiate between different kinds of
local minima it really depends on what
you expect this solution to then do for
example your training model is
generalization so so all that should we
should work it back and see what do we
expect from the optimization algorithm
based on that so I think I find the
questions itself it's very important I
have a one advice about coming with new
models is to actually work on
application so that was my direction in
the last few years I've been actually
going and working with people from the
sciences on problems that they have and
you know some of the downside of it is
that some of these problems are kind of
easy and if you just understand
aggression you can do them but quickly
you get into these problems that how do
i how do I analyze data that is so huge
how do I even pick the examples that I
should train on and and how should i I
think one of the things that that that I
found the most revealing is in many
cases you cannot think about machine
learning as
entity you have some process in the lab
and the lab and that process involves
decision making let's say finding micro
crystals in droplets okay and you want
to make that decision process more
efficient and you want people to trust
the updated decision process and so you
fit in we fit in something like boosting
but really the most important thing was
to decide how do we change the process
going on in the lab in terms of many
small decisions that are have to be made
so that that we really give them a
benefit and that from that I think you
can go back and come to active learning
and interactive learning and kind of
thing that Shaun joy is interested in
there's a concept in complexity theory
called smooth analysis as you know very
well which might possibly be applied to
validating some of these supervised
learning schemes the idea is to show
that even though you're yet review your
solution method may have errors it's
correct almost everywhere that is to say
that if you take any data point and
perturb it randomly slightly then with
high probability you'll get a modified
data point where the solution will be
correct
so it sounds like we mostly agree that
there's a great danger we are using
these models in ways that we don't fully
understand especially like the realm of
healthcare also are I think of the
recent example where there's some sort
of machine learning algorithm that's
being used in sentencing judges
sentencing and that's like extremely
racially biased so like as our community
is like putting out these models that we
don't fully understand and people are
applying them in ways that they hope
will understand like obviously problems
in a car so what do you think are some
like best practices to make sure that
we're using what's our obligation as
like the community of academics like
creating these models to make sure that
they're being used in ways that provide
the most insight and don't I think that
one of the most important things is to
be very careful about the data selection
process and the data labeling process
and evaluation so those are kind of
things that you and the potential user
should agree on this these are the ways
to do it and then when you go forward
you you actually are going to use those
processes to make so that your statement
at the end of the day that this works is
justified statistically
so I think right now hearing your
question that this is a great research
question and perhaps online learning
would have something to say about it how
to validate a model like after it is
deployed how to actually continue
exploring to estimate your the models
error while the model is actually in
current use my premise is a societal
question for a community of scholars and
this has kind of come up a number of you
have talked about safety but I want to
ask it just in terms of the progress
being made in the field and historically
other communities of scientists for
example physicists at Alamogordo with
the bomb in 1945 had to grapple with the
impact of the bomb genetic engineers in
1975 with the impact of gene editing
literally stopped doing research I have
the sense of this community despite what
I think Mike said about the lack of
quick progress might be on the bridge of
its star churn in terms of having a big
impact on the world and so do you think
that the responsibility lies with the
society around you or the individual
researcher through the community itself
have a responsibility for the
consequences of your technology I think
we're far from that level of
understanding those other communities
had so that they could actually track
forward consequences we're really far
from that I think though taking
responsibility for some of these things
and admitting that it's a research
problem and so on so just with the fake
news epidemic it was to be shocking and
real and still ongoing and I was pretty
disappointed Mark Zuckerberg standing up
and right after the election and sort of
saying well it's not our problem we're
just trying to put the stuff out there
well no we should take responsibilities
are changing the world at some level and
I don't think
lead to chaos necessarily immediately
but we have to think it through a little
bit we had we have say well that's a
research problem and you know and yes
there's a we have to partner with
lawyers and with sociologists and all
kinds of people we're not just a little
microcosm so we have to take
responsibility for being in a whole
technological infrastructure with other
people and not just be our little
computer scientists writing our
algorithms and putting out our code and
thinking that working to make the world
better period so there's a whole Silicon
Valley at those a lot of us of sort of
absorbs though you know we're shaking
the world we're doing all this novel
stuff and then the consequences be
damned so I don't think we're at the
point with the historic example she gave
her much more there was an imminent
danger but just this honesty and you
know talk about the speaker on the
dangerous let's be clearly uncertainties
here all that you don't get that when
you hear a lot of the stuff people talk
about about machine learning as soon as
we start to transition out there to the
outside world and yes it's partly always
a good point how do you excite the
younger dose of well we've overexcited
we've got them overheated I go to China
now and they just think that were you
know that artificial intelligence is now
everywhere and it's just we've solved it
and they just want to get in cash in on
the thing just MIT a book about point
two which I totally agree with take
machine translation which is you know
definitely gotten way better and Google
is now I apparently do with neural nets
and it's gotten heroes even a jump in
performance and so you have a lot of
people sort say well that's that
problems nearly solved kind of like
speech it's commoditize than anything
well yes and no if just from a pure
copying what humans can do taking a
sentence in and copying it over you know
it's not solved even there but it's kind
of you know becoming useful so you could
build companies around it right well I
speak several engines that I just know
that I did not take in trillions of
sentences in French and trillions the
sequences in English and I learned a
neural net to map between them right now
I have a semantic rubbage of the world
and I listen to the sentence I
understood it and then I kind of read
take it out in the other language and
and so yeah just building maps that
mimic what the data is out there is not
understand sign intelligence at all and
so as we get in these things like
dialogue and
that's language understanding and
question answering you know we are not
doing intelligent things and yes part of
it will show up with the lack of
robustness of these things translation
is not particularly boss dialogue will
be horribly non robust we just got to be
honest about that that we don't have
intelligence yet so I kind of actually
resent that it it should have been
called statistics they didn't got called
machine learning fine but then it called
Paul AI and I agree it was all about ia
and now suddenly everyone's calling it
AI as if we've solved the intelligence
problem what we haven't we're using
stochastic gradient sent with huge
amounts of data we didn't understand
anything I want to echo everything but
Mike said I just want to add that it is
an interesting paradox that in let's say
machine translation large neural
networks are being trained on Wikipedia
and tripadvisor and other things so it
seems that there is a model now of large
companies using what humans what well
trained you must do in their free time
so basically work using the small number
of you humans who are well trained and
the free work to actually make profits
in some sense and this is a very
interesting model I haven't seen it
anywhere else and it would be an
interesting look at where it where this
is going after she always over April
right in the early days of genomics
people in the community formed a
committee to set up guidelines for
certain kinds of for deciding which
genetic manipulations were too dangerous
to perform and it would be more
difficult to establish guidelines in
this field because of the extreme
diversity of applications but certainly
when machine learning the outputs of
machine learning programs
being used to control cars or
cyber-physical physical systems or
medical procedures it might be necessary
to get the feel to agree on some
standards of safety before proceeding
freedom this is actually similar to the
question that was just asked and I think
I mean it's some sense you're right that
the whole artificial intelligence thing
there's no intelligence going on but I
think that's really not the point the
point is that the technologies that are
being developed could really affect
society in a way very similar to how
manufacturing technology affected
textile industry 200 years ago where the
textile workers in England who because
of Technology started rioting and
crossing great societal unrest because
there they were out of work and in some
sense Buber is right now exploiting the
drivers so that they can become
profitable so that they can then develop
technology for self-driving cars that
will then make all these people who are
right now the bedrock of their profits
redundant and how to work and at the
same time they're not developing their
own skills so that they'll be useful in
the future they'll be basically out of
work out drivers with no skills they
spent there in several decades or
however long working on something that
not is now redundant and so I guess the
question from a theoretical computer
science perspective and like pumping
signals in statistics right so let's say
for example you wore it on real data set
that has nothing to do with the fact
that there might be a lack of social
acceptance of a decision that's made by
an algorithm that's not a human and so
so humans will want to hold responsible
an entity that makes mistakes somehow
right now we have humans who are making
these decisions and you know you can
we go and you can blame your doctor for
diagnosing you incorrectly for cancer
but when you have algorithms that assume
that despite how small your confidence
intervals are that could create that
those are new challenges and so the
question again this is there and is
there any way of formulating this from a
from a mathematical perspective it seems
like these these are challenges that may
may be beyond the ability to to discuss
mathematically at all yeah so I would
like to just give an example to just
show that yes you can actually do that
and and that there will be acceptance
eventually and it would be a good so I
work with pathologists and they do
analysis of prostate biopsy and process
biopsies and in case you don't know
they're huge images so they're basically
twenty thousand a thousand pixels a
pathologist a trained pathologist would
look through that slide about half a
minute and decide if there is cancer
there's just no way that they can
actually look at all the detail right so
they have some heuristics hopefully
their heuristic is good on the other
hand if we train whatever neural network
or our support vector machine to detect
cancer at the very minut case what we
can use that for is basically just to
direct them to the places where they
should look and make their work more
efficient right so so so I think that in
a lot of cases not in the driving in the
car driving
that's really I'm not a big believer in
that in that endeavor anyway so but but
in many decisions that have to do with
analyzing medical records analyzing
medical photography or AG or EEG people
are doing it now and they're doing it as
best as they can and computer can do it
better and computer can actually point
out the phenomena that would that the
human would agree that's really the
right phenomena so it's true that humans
want to keep the control in my ia
approach that's what I'm saying you know
you basically you are continuing to
analyze this but now I'm making your
work more efficient or more accurate or
whatever so so I think that there's just
kind of less alarmist ways to think
about these things that actually can
produce useful products and you know and
basically be good for the world i I
think that when we talk about the kind
of three alarming things technology is
doing like for instance Facebook you
know Facebook is a great thing everybody
can talk with everybody but then it also
gives bad actors new opportunities to
exploit people so so it's it's it's a
complicated decision you know whether to
okay should we disallow Facebook or
should we regulate Facebook maybe but
but all I'm saying is that these are not
technical question this requires a big
dialogue beyond our room right about
jobs and job displacement but it's a one
point I'd like make us the speed dis
change so that an industrial revolution
is sort of like 30 years for people to
adapt and I'm not sure I agree with the
comment that it's I would be a little
alarmist here there's a lot of jobs
could be lost much more quickly and so
yes all the people driving and I
actually I'm glad because there's 40,000
deaths a year we can turn off those
deaths you know with cars that's great
there's a lot of jobs loss really
quickly so then what do you tell them to
do well you become a
you go into call centers there's kind of
a typical one oh I don't know many truck
drivers who'd like to be in a call
center first of all but in five years
though the dialog systems will still be
crappy but they'll be good enough you
can get rid of lots and lots of call
centers and then where you tell them to
go five years later so that it's not
thirty years to adapt it's really really
quick that me is the big critical
difference and so yeah we got to be part
of the ongoing dialogue about where we
really think our technology can go on
what time frame so that people can start
to adjust and have real serious
discussions about it more quickly and
you can provision i i'm not as alarmist
in the long run though because i mean
you know society is adapted again and
again and again to waves of these kind
of things a example i'd someone
mentioned was massage therapist is a job
description a lot of people like a lot
of money be massage therapist a hundred
years ago there was no massage
therapists it did not exist right and
there will be brand new jobs created you
know that we just can't envisage at all
that seem kind of stupid now but you
know the idea of someone sitting behind
a wheel right now and sitting in a piece
of metal heard along a highway that's
kind of a you know we're job to have so
new ones will be create in some ways
could be more interesting but we got to
think about it really overtly
and so you know not to return to this
thing but you know talking about the
killer robots and you know and super
intelligent sticking or there's just so
much discussion to that that that's fine
at science fiction yes in four hundred
years that will be an issue we should
talk about it a little bit now but we
have got you're obviously right much
more pertinent problems in part is is a
separate issue than social unrest issue
i know but some can sort of rest on the
necessity being the mother invention and
wait for them other invention to occur
because of the necessity
yeah or you can sort of actively try to
avoid they like something of the
inevitable social unrest that could
could occur yeah so we got to be careful
slower less greedy more social it's kind
of you know i don't know how we could
get all this because our society seems
to be going the other way but the
emerging countries the u.s. is screwed
it up maybe china al
just a more optimistic question um this
wave of machine learning successes is
very exciting even from somebody who
doesn't understand it for practicing um
has it revealed to you anything
fundamental about computation itself but
nature of computation surprising new
algorithm definition here's an insight
that I didn't know right I just think we
don't have computational lower bounds
complexity theory delivered something
they're useful for certain other fields
for this field it didn't really yet and
I think that our notion of what the
model is for both getting up or lower
bounds needs to be average case it needs
to be specialized for certain situations
why is optimization theory played such
an important role because there's lower
bound Oracle's that are you know much
simpler computational models that
actually match the upper bound rates and
that's been a very very important way to
do so I think computation is a field
emerged an era that it came from a logic
and you wanted to solve the
computability problem what things can't
possibly be done and what is the
polynomial exponential barrier and all
that and we're just not in that world
we're in a different world other kinds
of models that are let's call them
average case but that didn't even do
justice to them but models that are more
specialized in certain situations that
give you more interesting tighter theory
whether it's more relevant computational
complexity theory has chosen to focus on
worst-case analysis which makes its
findings rather irrelevant for
situations where experience shows that
parallels of NP hardness really don't
occur in practical situations but there
has been no theoretical framework
proposed that really successfully
replaces the worst case analysis they
have been attempts at average case
analysis but the average case models are
too simplistic to be really interesting
in applications so I think there's a
real challenge to define models that are
more optimistic than worst-case and yet
not overly trivial in their formulation
it's an open question not only for
computational learning theory but for
all kinds of
editorial optimization really so I mean
there is an optimization theory lots of
average case analysis that's gone beyond
originally there was nemirovsky Newton
which was worst case and that was very
easily so good balance but now we have a
whole bunch of other models which are
average case that are it's not for all
of computational complexity and all
combinatorial problems but it's for
certain classes of optimization problems
and rabies so come to that end I mean
the taste of the community broadly has
been to come up with sort of lots of
regularity conditions all the kind of
hypotheses we're going to use for the
models and for the optimization
procedures that we would like to use but
part of this sort of like deep learning
story has been that people sort of throw
something at the wall and it sticks and
even though strictly speaking these you
know these things might be in some very
difficult complexity class and a lot of
this feels like it comes from the fact
that we are willing to make or can make
many fewer assumptions about the down
like the properties of the world right
and one of the kind of examples of the
success of that is like convolutional
neural networks where people are willing
to say that you know if I translate my
image around or something that doesn't
really affect the semantics we use this
image what is there any hope for us
developing theory about through the
properties of the data itself across
many different actual domains you know
it's kind of like an average case
situation but I don't know are we
completely there kind of any hope of
this theory of data a theory of data
well I mean there's a long tradition and
you know Derek layman here worked on
this sort of thing at Berkeley where you
suppose you have group actions on the
data so the data forms a set of points
that which can go into group actions
when the estimator should go under the
same group action these are called equal
variant people starting to return to
that widths come with some more
interesting groups that are these
that is exactly a theory about data that
turns in then to constraints on your
estimator it's just sort of limited in
the old days but especially if you go to
48 hours on groups kind of things you
can get a much repetitious that's okay
when the data is in D dimensional
Euclidean space but what if the data
consists of utterances in language how
do you get a reasonable model of that
class of object I just want to add that
there are various modeling assumptions
like that for instance
no good old Bayesian networks are a way
of describing the data that is very
flexible on top of it and somehow
interestingly related to the previous
question a problem that is hard and it
actually is a heart theoretically and
this heart approximate is inference in
Bayesian networks but when we talk about
models of computations you can think it
is good to look at what other progresses
have been made in other fields and
machine learning has been very good at
doing that like a look at optimization
you use and so on and we should probably
look at the region successfully which
side so first which is essentially a way
to solve many anti heart probably easily
until our
based on our promise I think I guess
along the lines of what these deep
neural networks as being excessive
representing distributions that are that
are much more complex than that the
distributions in period should be I
guess this sort of speaks to the idea
that optimization tends to work well
some other heuristics involving
regularization that's too complex oh
yeah yeah I mean you know the
computational challenges were they just
conceptual challenges that we don't
understand the data distributions well
enough to come up with more reasonable
models that's probably true it's
certainly true that the the deep nets
that are being used in these
successfully in these applications don't
have very much explanatory power for us
humans we look at them and we have no
notion what they're doing what features
they're representing whether they can be
simplified without losing their
effectiveness
it seems they do seem excessive somehow
I see it as a problem for the future to
be able to measure how much over
parameterization and neural network has
after it has been trained but
interestingly is that this has been
known for a long time that to predict
well is not the same as to find the
model of the understand the distribution
of the data well in fact if you want to
predict well you have to in some sense
you have to over parameterize for any
finite sample what we know for unless
you are in sufficiently large sample and
sufficiently large it is not known and
so this is this is what I CNN is in
interesting paradox that one cannot
explain and predict with the same model
in many by theoretical reasons in some
sense
so I think one way to think about it is
in terms of scaling so so there's a
trivial way to learn which is nearest
neighbors and basically we just store
all of the data and it tends to work
pretty well
now the problem there is that the amount
of of day of you know the size of the
representation is the size of the data
if you're talking about neural network I
would say that I would really be
convinced that it learns if the number
of parameters that you need stops to
increase as the amount of data is
basically hopefully become smaller but
but definitely that it should not need
to increase and it's a hard question to
kind of do do practically because we're
just doing some local search and find a
solution but in principle what what what
I would say about such a model is the
question is can you find a low
dimensional representation so can you
find something that does not increase so
you have basically the size of your
model does not increase
we're linearly with the size of the
table
dick they can be specified right
dramatically but a loan neural net can
be sparse by dramatically a write like a
question is still this the question is
still how many nonzero parameters would
it have as you increase the amount of
data the nonzero and binary at this
point so yeah it's a huge compression
noting that it's not a compression I'm
not saying that it's not a compression
I'm just asking about the scaling you
can compress also nearest neighbor
yes I can so many of us here in academia
and I think we have this common
experience that now there are these
cords of students who's you know who
really just want to learn about deep
learning
okay and I think you guys responsibles
colors most of us what we will be doing
is you know making sure they get all the
fundamentals and you know they learn
about you know all the various aspects
of machine learning before you know we
finally arrive at that one lecture about
that back propagation that they were but
so I think that's well and good but I
can't help feeling that you know in the
in the current context there is some
other stuff that we also need to be
teaching there you know something about
the you know I don't know like societal
impacts or you know all these sort of
things which are really not part of the
standard machine learning community that
was assigned any class but you know that
the community as a whole is developed
and
what what those things should be and
like what form it should be I mean it
the causal inference just take an
example we don't teach that I bet you
teach you to class yeah I mean I don't
see anyone she learning clouds out there
to teach it and for like medical domain
or anything that's it's all about you
know I give you your body I give you a
drug and that you actually like have a
causal effect on your getting better or
not all right so that's critical so how
can you do causal inference well you
know here's one while you do your
neighbor so the core problem causal
inference is not just a gradient descent
on a loss function problem it is a you
can only give me the treatment or the
control you can't give me both if you
give me both you could just subtracting
and get the causal effect you can't
right so you like it you do one or the
other but if you happen to have a twin
Mike Jordan there's always in properties
so if you ask neighbor you can find a
doppelganger for you know with anybody
you know hopefully in their buying space
or someone just like them and they
happen to gotten treatment you got
control and pull all the lows they're
not going to regression and you go has
anything off any stuff so you know you I
just taught it to you you could teach it
we could teach that to freshmen but
somehow we're not being motivated to
teach that and they can't excited about
that because they can do actual causal
inference of the world that's actually
smelling as exciting as taking an image
and same as a cabinet so I just think
we're kind of we don't have an
imagination to actually think of the
other classes about that I think that's
damn word AI is hurting us because it
would either cut students kind of guys
wanna learn about robots and vision
speech and languages right they don't
want to learn about bigger broader or
kinds of cause
infrastructure of our sciences we just
got to get people oriented those are
super exciting unsolved problems and
they are scientifically also just
teaching an a/b test so if you look at
Berkeley we designed a freshman level
class in let's call it we call the data
science because of the term of the day
but it was a valid a not a machine
learning class so one of things you do
if you go into industry on day one is
you have to do at a/b test you know very
common I have a head we have a current
website we get 10,000 hits a day we
changed the website to have red pixels
over here and we got you know not some
other number of hits right and you get
two columns of numbers old website new
website is it worth investing five
million dollars to change the website
well it's a question of whether those
two columns a number are different or
not how would you solve that right I bet
you don't teach that in your machine
learning class either and I bet you know
most of my machine advisors would even
know really how to do it they might say
well you do a t-test in that the right
thing to do well no there's the
permutation test which is that if they
really were coming from the same
distribution these two columns you could
stack them together win a super column
you could parade it randomly and under
exchange ability you break them into two
new columns
you're in the same distribution you do
that over and over again you're getting
the actual sampling distribution some
measure of difference between the
columns same variations you can ask
whether your original difference was in
the tail or in the middle so I just
taught you a be testing on the
permission and freshmen can understand
that and they can program in a Python
and they can try it on real data and
make inferences about is the population
in this county the same as the
population of the juries in this county
that's a cool social science problem so
I just think we should be getting out of
the AI I mean I hate to say this my
colleagues are all excited about
everything they're doing but we should
not just be in the AI sub world we
should say that we're broader than that
we're in the social science world we're
in the rest of computing world we're in
the communication bandwidth limitation
world we're in the physics and biology
world and you know so I wish somehow the
journals would go back to using ml
instead of AI because it really is a way
broader
enterprising worksite allopathy any more
final thoughts from the panel of
authority no sir we might have to keep
it short it's always happening love what
this pi/2 quite nice in surviving left
three look just stick to one oh just to
comment on Mike I mean Thomas Richardson
has a class on causal inference it's
been teaching for over is a statistician
yeah but it's a class on puzzling I know
but there's the statisticians are all
over that omission or not the collateral
gauges and I it's about computer science
versus statistics yeah it's a Sousa
colpo full of I bet school they're
together can see how many students the
upper class so he says it's a heat model
class and things and you have this paper
on algorithmic weakening which I thought
was a really amazing paper just
conceptually about their content and
that seems to be very promising way of
looking at large data sets any way which
I will behave possibly not theoretically
as data sets with larger algorithms I
think it's all one field of this
computer science and statistics are
really one deal the inference problem
with data moving it around being
intelligent about it
and they just happen to get broken apart
at some point but it's just it's crazy
that the future so yes all these that as
a paradigm well you should take the
pessimism of the statisticians to go the
optimism of the computer science belen
them and work all these wrongs together
everybody has we found works or the ones
let's like pow